dear fellow scholars we have just
reached 250 subscribers on the channel
so far the reception of these videos
have been overwhelmingly positive i'll
show you some of these comments on the
screen in the meantime 250 subscribers
this is probably not much compared to
even meet sighs youtubers but it means
so much to me it means that there are
250 people somewhere around the world
waiting for new videos to come up this
is insane if you think about it even one
subscriber is insane
even one click from somewhere is
mind-blowing imagine that someone who
have never met somewhere on the face of
earth perhaps in Peru somewhere in the
United States or maybe in the middle of
Africa is excited for your work and just
waiting for you to say something there
are millions of other videos they could
watch that they devote that time
listening to you and now multiply this
by 250 i am just sitting here in
disbelief
as a computer engineer I've been working
with computers and network algorithms
for a long time but i still find this
mind-blowing i can just record the
lectures that I hold at the University
and thousands of people can watch it at
any time even while i'm asleep at night
I can teach people while I am to sleep
at night
we have over a thousand views on my
first lecture which is possibly more
people than I will ever reach through
the university seminar rose
so for all 250 of you and everyone who
has ever watched any of these videos
thank you very much for watching and
subscribing i have created two minute
papers to show you the best of what
research can offer and what your
hard-earned tax money is spent on
because that's the thing every single
country have been to researchers are
complaining about the lack of funding
and rightfully so because most of them
can't secure the funds to continue their
work but let's try to turn the argument
around funding comes from your text
money and ninety-nine point nine percent
of the case you have no idea what your
money's spent on there are lots of
incredible works published every single
day of the year but the people don't
know anything about them
no one is stepping up to explain what
your money spent on and i am sure that
people would be happy to spend more and
research if they know what they invest
in two minute papers is here to
celebrate the genius of the best and
most beautiful research results i will
be trying my best to explain all of
these works so that everyone is able to
understand them
it's not only for experts it's
definitely for everyone so thank you for
all of you
thanks for hanging in there and please
spread the word let your friends know
about the show so even more of us can
marvel at these beautiful works and
until then i'll see you next time